so let's move to our own border we spent
a lot of time talking about other
people's borders and dropping bombs on
them yet ours is wide open and now Joe
Biden and Democrats and with some
Republicans are pushing this border bill
that we're supposed to this weekend uh
get the text of and we've heard rumors
of what it might be about um here's a
quick breakdown of the Border bill of
the $106 billion package proposed in
this is from October so this is what was
previously proposed 61 billion for
Ukraine 14 billion for Israel and then
13 billion for Border enforcement we
don't know if that will match exactly
what this bill is you have the tough job
of being the lead liaison between the
house and the Senate so you try to
coordinate I mean is there any
coordinating here this bill feels like
it's Dead on Arrival especially amongst
House Republicans well it is tough
because the House Republicans and Senate
Republicans like hr2 hr2 is the golden
standard and we would love to have hr2
it's just not possible when you're
dealing with an Administration that
leaves in an open border but we also
know that it's a national security risk
so we kind of have to lower the bar a
little bit I hate to say that but we
don't own the White House and we
definitely don't leave the Senate either
that's Chuck Schumer so doing nothing
isn't really in the best interest so
what is our goal going through this
process our goal was one to stem the
flow of illegal immigrants we can't take
it to zero we could if president Trump
was in office but this guy's had a wide
open border since he's been in office I
mean reversed all the uh all the
executive orders that Trump had in place
which is whyde underneath Trump we had a
secure
he says now that if we pass the Bill
he'll shut the border down he doesn't
need the bill pass to shut the border
down first of all but our goal is one
these are three pillars one we want to
make sure that we St the flow two we
have to change the Asylum process
remember president Trump tried to change
the Asylum process H they took him to
court and the liberal Court kick it out
well we're going to change the Asylum
process through this bill and three we
have to change the pro process right now
85% of the 8.8 million people that's
crossed the border uh and got claimed
Asylum and got pared um those 85 uh 85%
of those were automatically pared into
the United States without any background
check this bill will change that where
they they the burden of proof needing
meaning that they can't simply say the
magic words I fear my government they
have to prove why they feared and there
was no safe place for them to go to in
their country or on their travels which
by the way Pete that would be very
difficult because the North American
pack between Mexico United States and
Canada says if you enter their country
first then you can claim Asylum because
they're considered a safe country so in
other words all those individuals going
to Mexico to get to our Southern border
underneath this new rule would have to
claim asylum in Mexico so we the the
percentage of individuals being able to
cross the border and be a to claim
Asylum without being sent back would be
next to nothing and then the then the
deportation on a separate note
deportation right now will take
sometimes six to 10 years for a hearing
uh underneath the S on this will take a
matter of day
matter days before they can get I hear I
hear what you're saying Senator it'll be
interesting to hear see what it looks
like when the text comes out there's
talk of this 5,000
thres mind yeah but a lot of people's
made their mind up that they're not
voting for this bill and they haven't
read it that's like saying why did you
vote for a bill that you never read
either everybody should take a deep
breath and and read the bill before we
decide if we're going to support it or
we're not going to support it absolutely
so we look forward to the text of the
bill we may get it today we'll be able
to discuss it tomorrow and then we'll
have a conversation from there
appreciate that Senator Mark Wayne
Mullen thanks for your time thank you
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kil and I'm
Angy aart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis